foreign
so today I want to talk to you about
something a little bit different uh
largely when we have conversations about
race and gender
we focus on politics
we focus on our sensibilities of how we
think we should act towards people and
we focus on what we take to be an
obvious and intuitive visibility if our
patriarchy gender works specifically the
oppression of women
what I like to do today is move Beyond a
conversation of politics
to understand and diagnose how white
supremacist patriarchal societies
actually operate towards groups of
racialized men excluded from that
Society
we've made General assumptions largely
coming out of the birth of second wave
feminism in the 1960s and 70s about how
gender operates
the field that I started blackmail
studies takes a social scientific and
conceptual view of how patriarchies
around the world actually operate and
what we find when we empirically
investigate genocides Imperial conquests
ethnic conflict racist regimes is that
patriarchy seek to exterminate
subordinate and racialized Men First in
genocides and then throughout the rest
of the repressive regime
now despite this obvious and historical
fact that we could trace all the way
back to Antiquity there's very little
conversation about how subordinate and
racialized men are actually oppressed by
patriarchal white supremacists and
racist societies so we try to remedy
that in the study of black men and their
vulnerability
now when I was at in the United States I
gave a lecture for black academics
and academics is like the black Ted Talk
all right
and I said I challenge the audience to
think about this seriously
that while we'll disown the racist
caricatures of black men and boys as
super predators
we simultaneously imagine them as voids
vacuous figures that we're fine not
knowing we don't care about how they
suffer during their lives but love
performing outrage at their deaths
so black men and boys in the United
States have been shown to the world
largely as victims of police violence
the popularity of BLM in the UK the
protest for racial Justice uses the
black male body as a symbol
but the corpse signal something to the
world
is dead flesh
it represents nothing but the
interpretation that the world seeks to
impose upon it
which is why many of the conversations
surrounding the death of young black men
and boys in the United States revolves
around the demonization of their lives
we all know Emmett Till
Emmett Till became a symbol of civil
rights
but I want you to pay attention to
something
don't focus on the grotesque nature of
what happened to this young man
ask yourself a more fundamental question
what does it show us
what does it demonstrate to us the
mutilated black melt body
we're disgusted that by the fact that
something like this could happen to a
human being
but I ask you to think about the fact
that young black boys in the United
States have never been seen as human
beings
and I don't mean that rhetorically
I don't mean to create the impulse that
oh we must reach towards Humanity
I'm asking you to conceptualize more
seriously the fact that in contemporary
Western democracies we have groups of
popular people populations that are not
seen as human or are treated as such
and if we take that as a starting point
of how we analyze questions of racism
and particularly particularly the
racialized male situation
can we be surprised that this is the
outcome
does this not seem like the
inevitability of people who live in our
contemporary societies but are still
dehumanized
this is something that ran in National
Geographic a few years ago
it was celebrated because it was trying
to show the suffering that mothers had
to the death of young black men and boys
now to most people this would seem
unproblematic but ask you this question
what living being is presented to the
world as a corpse
what is it in the imagery of black men
as quantitative numbers statistics
that are no longer alive
that so motivates the world to pay
attention
but notice in this image it's not the
black boy that's the focus of this
editorial it's the black mother
so like Emmett Till
where the black mother decided to show
the world the horror the empathy that we
have for the situation goes to the
mother and not to the void that is the
black male
can we empathize or sympathize for black
men and boys and if we can't what is it
that makes that quality so palatable
so what I want to do is start with some
very basic social scientific facts about
black men and boys that I really think
drives this point home
so for those who don't know in the
United States black males have the
lowest life expectancy of any group
now after covid that life expectancy
decreased another three years so roughly
black men live between 67 and 70 years
compared to the rest of the population
now while people look at this and say
well men generally die earlier Etc
what I ask you look is a negative slope
the disparity
why are we so comfortable with the
absence of a certain demographic in a
population
if we are indeed a Democratic Society
what is it about the black male
population the negative stereotypes
criminals rapists lower IQs and their
female counterparts and whites thieves
what is it that we're so comfortable
accepting
about this group such that it not only
justifies their exclusion but they're
outright absence if not disappearance
from our social spaces this is a curve
showing the percentage of survival
curves showing the percentage of black
men or black males that reach the age of
20.
think about that 20 years old
someone who barely gets past their
teenage years
see back in the 1970s two sociologists
argue that the difference between
American racism and the liberal
conceptualization of racism is
discrimination was that blackmail suffer
from institutional decimation
now James Stewart and his co-author
suggested that if we look at how racism
actually operates moving from
segregation to an integration to society
we don't get the promise of racial
equality that we thought in other words
desegregation did not eliminate both the
state and social pressures to eliminate
groups they thought were threats to
White Society
now while that's an unpopular view for
people who think that civil rights and
democracy have moved us to the promised
land to a truly civil intolerant Society
you have to ask yourselves
why is it that the exemptions we find in
the society are so powerful and mimic
what we've seen throughout history
said differently
what is it about the spectacle of
lynching about the mutilation of black
male bodies that seems so repetitive
that seems like such a persistent
technology of racial oppression that we
could both recognize the deaths of young
black men and boys in the United States
as a terror and a lynching that mimics
and imitates what we've seen throughout
history especially with that of him
until
now a lot of focus has come on the
killing of black people by police in the
United States
I'll tell you growing up in the United
States I'm from the south I've had guns
pulled on me more times than not
well the first times actually was when I
was in grad school of DePaul University
I actually had a pea coat on in the
middle of the winter with a chest bag
around my around my chest going to the
chess club
two cops came up to my window pointing
guns at me and one was behind me right
like in on his on this edge of the
window with his gun pointing to me so
three guns pointed at me all right
I remember I didn't tell my mom at the
time she would have made me come home
but
but it tells you something my heartbeat
didn't even jump
because I knew that if it did it'd be an
excuse for them to shoot me dead right
there
now imagine that
don't imagine that as a racial situation
a horrible racial circumstance imagine
that as the condition that black boys
are trained to deal with from birth
imagine being in a society so hostile to
you that your death doesn't even flicker
in terms of the societal Norms that you
have
so when we talk about gender when we
talk about patriarchal oppression hell
when we talk about racism
it's not to intimate an idea of
unfairness
rather it's talking about actual
processes that overwhelming European
countries have used to experiment with
various strategies of death and dying
against a marginalized racial population
so if we start thinking about racism as
a process that brings about death then
it's not surprising to see why black men
are two and a half times more likely to
be killed by police and black women are
about 1.4 times more likely be killed by
police than white women
and while people have tried to play this
out in the media as a kind of gender War
I urge you just to look at the facts
that means that 96 per 100 000 black men
will be killed
compared to five point four per hundred
thousand other female counterpart
think about that despaired
so then what does it mean to suggest
being male in patriarchal white
societies our privilege our power
your life chances are almost cut in half
but we don't have an analysis to think
about the ways that oppression is
systemically intertwined with the desire
that white societies have to be rid of
these groups of people
and that's why I asked to nurse you when
you start thinking about the ways that
white societies regulate themselves deal
with undesirables choose not to let
certain migrant populations into the
country then you're dealing with the
deliberate strategy engineered by the
state and the population to make sure
not only that the population looks a
certain way but that it has the proper
and legitimate Democratic means to
exterminate and eliminate populations
that it sees fit
and that's what's interesting about the
vulnerability of black men boys
the disparities that you see in terms of
Lifetime risks means that black men and
boys live in a situation of surveillance
and I want to stress this point
that means that within a Democratic
Society that we claim has evolved and
free a civil society that is supposed to
be based on recognition and dialogue we
have absolutely no problem accepting
that genocidal mechanisms and techniques
are being used towards a certain
population
so that means that there is not an
incompatibility between surveillance
death and other strategies of dying that
we take to be incompatible with a free
Society
studying black men and boys points out
this contradiction it is not an urge for
us to incorporate them into some system
of recognition that the tugs at the
heartstrings of the white population
rather in studying the vulnerability of
black men and boys we understand that it
points out the contradiction of our
systemic and conceptual analysis that
democracy not only thrives instead of
fails with the murder of certain people
but is accepted as a norm and better for
the society
people have become enriched Darren
Wilson became I almost became a
millionaire
when he killed a young boy in Missouri
the you have white people contributing
to the Justice fund and the enrichment
of white people largely white men who
are killing black men and boys in my
country
so where's the outrage where's the
disgust
is it simply in the political movements
to happen to make it across the ocean
but then you ask yourself the question
despite the celebration and recognition
of black lives matter has the deaths of
black men decreased
and the answer is no
so in Ashley planned Joe Palin and
kutzman study
they actually wanted to understand the
trigger that blackmailness had in the
minds of whites
so utilizing college-educated white
students what they showed was that white
participants showed a pronounced bias
towards shooting black men
but a bias away from shooting black
women and white in-group members
participants in their study were biased
away from shooting the female suspects
even when the female suspects were armed
specifically when responding to black
and white women participants tended to
make more mistakes of not shooting armed
suspects than mistakenly shooting
unarmed suspects
so that's what this looks like
look at the error and shooting unarmed
black men and this is what people this
is what I mean this is real time a bunch
of college educated
white people
were more likely to shoot an unarmed
black man than armed white men armed
white women armed black women
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas